[Music]
she's a boss I shared with her my story
of you know growing up in Florida
watching that's a raven it was my
favorite show I could quote you lines
Raven was my best friend in my mind for
years as she was for many people I have
moments where I catch myself just
staring at her like are you real like am
I really doing this right now it's not
only been a dream come true to work with
her
it's made me a better actor
are you actually doing your job
I had to take a passport photo and they
said I needed a bland background so
obviously I came here the first
live-action trans character on Disney
Channel that's incredible every time I
hear it
I get emotional but at the same time I'm
also like did I really hear that right
am I like really experiencing this it's
a version of my dreams that I could not
have dreamed Nikki just because your
transgender doesn't make you different
right it makes you amazing no I'm not
different because I'm trans I'm
different because I'm an heiress
what are people saying to you about
Nikki I've had some very very very very
beautiful messages trans youth saying
house seeing they feel to see an out
trans person and character on Disney
Channel but also family members of trans
people it's chained a few people's minds
which I love we're human and we're
deserving of of not just playing these
roles on camera
but living these lives behind camera
[Music]